so do you need me to use this or can I
just project to the back of the room can
you hear me all the way in the back
fantastic so that way I can be a little
bit mobile so this talk is called design
principles now of course there are so
many design principles that we could
talk about in the design of software
that I picked one and I think one that's
very important which is talking about
complexity something that we talk about
a lot and I want to dive in I want to do
a few musings on complexity as it were
so before we get started we're at PI
data DC hosted at Capital One its Sunday
October 9 2016 and I'm James Powell if
you like this talk you can tweet at me
at don't use this code on Twitter or you
can send me an e-mail at James that
don't use this code calm now one thing
that if you've been to other Pi Day
events you may have seen talks that I've
given and one thing that I've developed
some reputation for in my talks is
writing very provocative code I like to
write code to really provoke people to
make them think about things
thus the email address and Twitter
handle don't use this code it's kind of
a disclaimer built into everything I do
just to say this might be interesting
but I'm not saying that you're actually
what ever used this I've given talks
about metaclasses and Python features I
given talks about generators I've given
talks about a project I did called pi/3
so2 where I embedded a Python one
interpreter into a Python two into a
Python 3 so you could run Python 2 and
Python 3 code in the same process and
they could interact with each other I
wrote a little tool called our watch
where you could add read watches to
Python that could subsist dramatically
change the way the interpreter works
this one nobody seemed to really like
but I wrote a you can write LD preloads
in Python and it was a real puzzle to
try and figure out how to actually link
them but I can write LD preloads in
Python so I was able to write in Python
and about 30 lines of code and LD
preload so that any arbitrary program on
my computer that was written in C could
transparently work with zip files
without having to know there was it
files my LD preload just intercepted
open read write and close and all those
other calls to give you unzip data and
then transparently zip it back I thought
that was kind of cool and in
this year I gave a talk called from past
import print statement where I added the
print statement back into Python 3 you
know it was a fun joke I'll say that for
my talks are not all party tricks but it
is true that they are often very
self-indulgent the reason for that is
you know it's kind of fun it's kind of
fun to see what you can do within a
Python interpreter how you can bend the
rules and how you can bend the rules
without quite breaking them I would say
if there's a legitimate reason why I
give these talks it's to kind of explore
the space of possibilities behind what
you can really do how you can take your
knowledge of Python your knowledge of C
Python specifically your knowledge of
how the C runtime works and really drive
it as far as possible and my goal in
that is to show you some tools to solve
actual problems now I'll admit to you
that these are problems that you might
never ever have in fact these may be
problems that you might hope to never
have but you might eventually run into
and if that were to happen it would be
nice to be able to solve them it would
be nice to know what exists at the
frontiers at the boundaries of our
knowledge so that on that fateful night
you know come 3:00 a.m. you put down
your phone you stop tweeting because
you've gotten uh that was a political
joke nobody okay I'll keep the political
jet will it will we're done with
political jokes for this year I guess
but you know it would be nice to be able
to solve some of these very hard
problems and a surgical fashion as
possible and so a consequence of the
construction of these talks is that they
they showed very complex things you do
with Python in order to entertain the
audience that is the complexity of the
solution was a direct was directly
correlated to how entertaining it was
supposed to be and I never really talked
about applicability you know would you
ever really do this and I never really
talked about justifying the complexity
does it really make sense to live patch
your Python interpreter to add some
features as opposed to just making do
with what you have I will say though
that this question of complexity is one
that I see come up constantly it is an
elusive question and a very important
question I would say that this is
probably one of the most important
questions that we ask ourselves as
programmers that we ask ourselves
constantly the other question would be
how do we determine what constitutes
good code and what constitutes bad code
and for those of you who never seen it
in my talks I can tell you I already
know what good code and bad code is and
I can tell you very simply in the span
of two slides exactly how you can
distinguish between good code and bad
code simply enough good code is code I
wrote bad code is code you wrote and
really it doesn't go any further than
that that's supposed to be pretty
provocative to the idea there being that
often times what we consider to be good
code is really just a reflection of our
own prejudices and I think that this
happens in the same situation when we
have to decide whether or not we want to
write complex code now one question you
might presume is based on my prejudices
of having indulged in all of this
complexity and having done all these
weird things in the C Python interpreter
I might be telling you you should write
complex code you should you should take
the sophistication that I present in
these talks and go hog-wild with them
and add them to production systems and
the don't use this code is really a
wink-wink type of thing but it's not
because i'll tell you right now i don't
think you should write complex code in
fact i don't think you should even solve
complex problems at least not for money
and I mean that very seriously because
you know as as engineers for us what's
most important is the applicable value
of a problem not how hard it is you know
in our spare time when we're at home
when we're having fun the hardness of a
problem might be very satisfying but it
doesn't necessarily drive any value I
work as a consultant and in many cases
there's a lot of risk in what I can
deliver in terms of value to somebody
I'd rather solve the easiest problem I
can because I know I can get it right
and I know I can get a paycheck at the
end of the contract
fundamentally difficulty of our problem
is a risk factor complexity is a risk
factor that's added to our engineering
process now some people would say that
complexity is a competitive advantage
it's not it's not a competitive
advantage and you often hear this come
out in many different ways you'll talk
to people and they'll be bragging about
the complexity of the problem they're
trying to solve their business model
they'll tell you something like oh yeah
we're doing this at scale we're an
advertising company and we have billions
of requests per second you know it's so
difficult we have to have
sub microsecond response times and
things like that and when you look a
little bit closer you'll see they're
guided towards that not because it was
an interesting problem or because it was
something they wanted to solve it's
usually because they had to have that
level of complexity they had to have
those response times or those number of
messages in order to be profitable and
so when I hear people tell me about how
difficult their stat you know how
difficult the problems are trying to
solve our in my mind it sounds like them
saying let's start an airline because
the margins are really thin and that's
not the kind of business I want to be
and I want to solve easy problems that
are very valuable solving hard problems
can be a competitive strategy you could
talk about complexity capture in the
same way that you might talk about
regulatory capture the idea being that
you invite complexity into the problem
that you're trying to solve in order to
engage your opponents on some ground
that's not favorable to them so you know
you can move faster on this ground than
they can you know that you have better
programmers than they have and so you
try and trap them in some area where
they can't compete so it's more of a
competitive strategy than a competitive
advantage but I would say even then I
find this fairly uncompelled because I
think difficulty or complexity as a
barrier a competitive barrier in a
marketplace really is a very shallow
moat the reason for that is there's
always somebody out there who will fight
you by finding a cheaper easier problem
to solve and I think generally that's
what we see in the marketplace you try
and solve a very hard problem you put a
lot of resources in solving that hard
problem you put all your weight behind
solving that hard problem and some small
start-up solves 80% of that problem much
cheaper than you can and you're out
competing this is of course part of the
reasoning behind this mantra of worse is
better that often times solving the
entirety of the problem that the problem
itself is sufficiently negotiable that
solving the hardest problem might not
actually be as valuable I would say that
I would encourage you in general to only
solve our problems where they are
disproportionately valuable complex
problems can sometimes be
disproportionately valuable to how
complex they are and those are the
problems you want to tackle so I'm not
here to tell you that you should just
enjoy complexity just because that's
something that I've shown in my talks
now there's still a core question
of one is complexity desirable or in
other words when is complexity justified
and we all have an intuitive answer to
this we've all cursed our way through
incredibly complicated code we've all
worked on some project and we said why
on earth they do it this way and just
cursed from the moment we saw the moment
we got access to the repository to the
moment we were able to put in our change
request or our pull request and we've
also seen this problem from a more
quantitative approach we've heard people
talk about lines of code or cyclomatic
complexity or heaven forbid k complexity
in trying to quantify how complex a
piece of code is and say well this is a
little bit too much bicyclic cyclomatic
complexity perspective but what I'm
trying to drive here is a more qualified
justification what qualitative metrics
can we use to really try and figure out
are we going off the deep end and I
would argue that the qualitative metrics
that we have right now at least the
aphorisms that we have in our industry
right now are exceptionally poor one of
them is a phrase that I absolutely hate
which is keep it simple stupid and the
moment somebody says to me keep it
simple stupid the only thing I can think
is no you're the stupid one but I mean
this in two ways I mean that's in two
ways the first way is that I often see
this phrase used to cover up for
deficiencies somebody says keep it
simple stupid because essentially we all
kind of try to code to our own to our
own level of competence so you know
there's some reason why they don't want
to engage a certain degree of complexity
a certain degree of sophistication and
the code you write because that's
putting them into unfamiliar territory
and you'll see this in some very
interesting ways I mean I'm sure you've
all talked to somebody who said oh you
know version control is a little bit too
much why can't I just tarball everything
and you know if you went back 20 or 30
years you'd hear people say structure
programming now that's just fluff we
could just use go to everywhere and the
argument here is that you know we all
have some barrier for what we consider
to be too complex and not complex enough
and to say keep it simple stupid because
it's just beyond what we know is I feel
a fairly uncompelled argument now I
should qualify that by saying that it's
okay not to know something I'm not
diminishing people by saying that if you
don't know something or if you don't
have a certain level of technical
sophistication that's wrong it doesn't
diminish you as a human being and it
doesn't diminish you as an effective
contributor to a project what I am
saying is for all of you here in the
audience for every pair of you here in
the audience there exists some level
complexity some example such that one of
you would say that's too much and one of
you would say no that's necessary to
solve the problem for any gift for we
could find a problem where you would say
no I think that's a little bit too much
let's do it a simpler and Tom castle
would say well you know what we actually
need to do it that way or Bobby falar
would say no I actually disagree and so
there's always some some distinguishing
level of complexity where we're not
going to agree in essence simplicity is
not some uncontested good and when
people say things like keep it simple
stupid it reminds me of a slogan I heard
from a start-up we're all familiar with
Facebook's corporate motto move fast and
break things and I read a blog post a
couple years back about a startup that
wanted to have their model as move fast
and don't break things and I thought
that's absurd because as though it were
so easy right I would say a better view
of this is if we look at the Zen of
Python we see that two lines of the Zen
on Python address this head-on
they say simple as better than complex
and complex is better than complicated
and the essence here is that simple
isn't something we can't just write
simple code as though it were something
that we could just do there's always
going to be some reason why there's
complexity in our code and what we're
trying to avoid is not complexity but
complication and I think the Zen of
Python tries to tease out that just that
a little bit more I'd say the second
reason why I don't like keep it simple
stupid is that I think it's only
valuable as a statement that you say to
yourself I told you no you're the stupid
one well that's the truth when you're
saying keep it simple stupid that's
something you're saying to yourself
you're calling yourself stupid because
you're trying to say let's not get
carried away because we all know that
when we're working on a project there's
some degree of self-indulgence
we get so wrapped up in solving the
problem that we might try something just
to scratch that itch that maybe isn't
that valuable to anybody in an
organization I would say that
fundamentally what distinguishes writing
code as an engineer versus writing code
as a software programmer is that
engineering fundamentally is work
subordinated to some process
when you write code as an engineer your
subordinating yourself to some goals of
some organization so maybe you maybe the
codes not the code that you want to
write maybe it's not code that's
interesting to you intellectually but
the satisfaction you get is from serving
the needs of the organization not
serving your intellectual needs but I'd
say the question still remains how do we
distinguish between something that is
unnecessarily complex and something that
is irreducibly complex and I want to
give you an example from our talk that I
gave a long long time ago
one of the most maligned features in the
Python languages metaclasses
this is a feature where I've seen very
talented Python developers give talk
saying don't use meta classes they're
too confusing they're too complicated
they don't do anything
there are stupid approach don't use them
and people who should know better now I
will argue that if you have a strawman
example that looks something like this
then you're a hundred percent right this
is a meta class that swaps the order of
derivation so a base class in a drive
class gets swapped this is absolutely
and totally unnecessary the problem it
solves it doesn't I don't even know for
certain that it would solve the problem
that it's supposed to solve and haven't
forgot I can't even understand what I
looked over that when I looked at the
code I can't even understand how it
works it's just beyond the pale that
said what I would argue for you is that
for each of the mechanisms that were
introduced to a programming language
like Python there's generally a reason
for that and if you if you dig deep
enough you might find what that reason
is these mechanisms are merely tools to
accomplish some goal in the case of a
meta class I would say that there's
actually a fairly clear goal for what
they accomplished meta classes are our
tool in Python for enforcing constraints
from a base class to a derived class
dead stop and almost every justifiable
application of that is enforcement
straight from a base class to a dry
quest what do I mean well we have two
classes we have a base class and we have
a derived class
base and derived right if we want to if
we want a constraint that goes from the
derived class to the base class for
example we want to say our derived class
and asserts that the base class has a do
it method then we might have some code
in some file that has class base and we
can't touch that file not even know
where it is and we have in some other
file our derived class
our drive class we put a little assert
at the top and we say assert that that
base class has some attribute so that in
our code when we call run it
we know that the do it was implemented
by the base class and if it wasn't then
this code would never compile in Python
it would never get past the module
evaluation step because the assert would
trigger now that's not actually true
because asserts are not a runtime
checking mechanism in Python because if
you do - oh the asserts are disabled so
if you wanted to add a little bit of put
perhaps unnecessary complexity you
really should do it like this what that
has a door check and raising your own
type error but the idea being that if
you in a derived class want to make sure
that the base class has some properties
on it you can do that because you put
that code right next to where you write
the derived class and fundamentally in
this example you're the one writing the
derived class and somebody else has
written the base class how do you do it
the other way around how do you have
your base class and force a constraint
on the drive class how do you write some
code and then say everybody who needs to
derive from this has to follow some
rules metaclasses are basically the only
mechanism to do that so in this example
you have some base class that have some
run it method that calls some do it
method you don't implement it you're
enforcing that everybody else implements
it this is some kind of interface
pattern or abstract method pattern and
in fact if you look at Python in the ABC
meta library they have the ability to
mark abstract methods on Python instance
methods and it just uses a metaclass
construction a little bit more
sophisticated than one I'm going to show
you so in some other file you have your
derived class and you can't touch the
original file so all you do is you add
some meta class and it says whenever I'm
constructing a new type I just make sure
that new type has a do it method and if
it doesn't I raise the type here and
then you add that to your base class and
everything that derives from a type
which have the metaclass on it derives
that medic lass so the base class has to
have a do it method and I set it to none
this is a almost ridiculous equivalence
to setting a virtual method and C++ to
zero how preposterous is that and the
derived class necessarily has to have a
do it method otherwise the Python
constructor won't construct that class
and there are actually two or three
other mechanisms to do the same thing in
Python there's build class there's an it
subclass
and python - there's one other mechanism
but fundamentally what you can see is
there's a goal that we have we have some
code that has some constraint that it
needs to enforce and this is the only
mechanism that we have to do that via
code so when you come to me and you say
I don't like meta classes I saw a talk
by so-and-so and I've told don't ever
use them they're too complicated and you
say I don't want to use meta classes
then I'm going to say fine you don't
want to use them you're gonna end up
using them in one or the other or you
can end up doing something much worse
because when you want to make that
concern you want to enforce that
constraint for example in a real
situation I saw where we had a unit
testing suite and in that unit testing
suite we had to set up a test DB and all
of the unit tests that we wrote and in
order to have the test DB we have to
call super set up and a bunch of people
are forgetting to call super set up and
their unit tests for writing against a
production database or their writing or
they were failing because they weren't
initializing some special fields for the
database and somebody said well we need
to make sure in everybody's unit tests
they call super set up in their setup
method well there's a common base class
and that base class needs to make sure
in all the derived class at everybody
else writes the set up the super set up
meant that it's called that's exactly
the pattern that we're looking for and
so this is how you solve it and so I
spent 30 minutes so I wrote them a 25
line metaclass that would do it and I
said this is a solution and they said I
don't want to use it I saw a
presentation it's a bad idea and instead
they wrote something looks like this
they wrote a little bit of code that
used regular expressions to parse every
file in our system and send an email to
people where it didn't seem to have a
super set up line under a set up line
under a test line and was about a
thousand lines of code long and it sent
out a lot of emails and it required a
lot of change requests and there's still
some stuff that slept slip through the
cracks but they said I think this is a
better approach and we could argue
whether it's a better approach or a
worse approach because maybe I'm wrong
maybe I'll argue that the code is much
shorter in my example and it's much
safer and it works but they might argue
that sending emails gets you some
visibility so you know it's good to let
the boss know that you're working and
and it's it's obvious for a newbie to
look at the metaclass might be a little
bit too too much for if the sort task
that a junior programmer working on
might be a little bit too too far beyond
what we could expect of them and so I'll
admit I might be wrong but in this
presentation one of my goals is to avoid
giving you really boring answers boring
answers like qualified judgment is it
depends or qualified judgment means it's
a series of trade-offs I hate these
answers so they don't say anything so
what I want to give you and the last
portion of this presentation is a very
simple framework that I use to determine
where complexity can be applied this
framework doesn't work in all
circumstances but I found that it can
sometimes help me justify decisions that
I make about is this too much or not
it's based on the idea that we can
quantify things in a very fuzzy fashion
just thinking a budget so we have a
complexity budget our projects has a
budget that says you know here's some
complexity that were willing to spend as
part of this and there's generally two
considerations for whether we want to
and what what how big that budget should
be one is how sophisticated are our
users do you want to optimize our code
for a junior programmer for a newbie
does it make sense to optimize our code
for newbies when there's three newbies
or there's three junior programmers and
a hundred senior programmers does it
make sense that we had to optimize our
code for newbies when we have three
newbies but in six months time they'll
be up to speed should we really optimize
our code for those six months when
somebody just joins the organization not
that 12 years when they stay here and
those are all reasonable considerations
one example that I'll tell you that you
can see this in is see Python if you
ever look at the Python interpreter you
can see that it's intentionally written
to avoid fancy constructions in C it's
intentionally written to be hacked on by
fairly fairly junior C programmers in
fact I can promise you after this
presentation within 25 minutes of time I
could get every single one of you in
this room up to speed on how to hack on
C Python and all you need is a C
compiler on your computer and you need
to be able to read through like an if
statement in a switch statement and
that's it C Python is written to be
hacked on by amateurs and as a
consequence it is a very flexible
interpreter that has a lot of
contributors it's a very low bar for
contributors and so you have a very
active C Python contribution I believe
the number that I
I saw was 1692 total contributors to
cpython
over the last 26 years so it's a very
low bar and it works exceptionally well
for that project
the other consideration for setting this
complexity budget I think is how much do
your users really care do they care
about the code or do they just care
about the results and what is your
expectation for them to learn about this
artifact that you've created this code
that you've created and I think if you
return to Python you can see this as
well when Python first emerged in the
language 25 or 26 years ago people
naturally are not going to care about it
that much they're gonna see it as a tool
that accomplishes some work but they're
not going to spend all of their time
learning about it because from a
perspective of I want to learn tools
that are useful for me professionally an
up-and-coming tool isn't quite there yet
and so a lot of choices that were made
in the original design of Python more
choices to let's not rock the boat too
much let's just rely on defaults
provided by the operating system let's
not build our own layers of systems
let's not add need crazy features that
people would be mystified by and as the
project grows over time in the ensuing
25 or 26 years there is more of an
incentive for people to care about how
Python works for them to really sit down
and understand the language and so
there's greater budget for the language
itself to develop complexity in terms of
fancy features like async i/o async
await generators and so forth I like to
think of this as if we graph these two
things on an axis how how much the users
care and how much they're expected to
know how sophisticated they're expected
to be we end up you know what the top
axis kind of say are we talking about
smart users or dumb users and are we
talking about users who care or don't
care about their code I will fix this a
little bit though because I don't want
to imply that knowing something means
you're smart and not knowing means
something means you're dumb cuz I think
that's a pretty offensive thing to say
additionally I don't want to imply that
don't caring about a tool means you
don't want to use it it just means you
don't want to learn you don't want to go
out of your way to Bend yourself to that
tool in order to make use of it so I'll
change my graph a little bit and we'll
talk about sophisticated vs. users who
are developing sophistication or to keep
it small we'll just have it like that so
you can think of the D as whatever you
want but if you want to be
polite to our friends it's those who are
developing sophistication our users who
are not expected to be expert
programmers expert data scientists
expert at the field William and I'll
show you a couple of quick case studies
just to show how I've used this
framework one case study is stylistic
complexity so we often see cases where
you could write code looking like this
you have some modality and you encode
that modal in your function using and if
you're using some control flow structure
and somebody else comes in and says well
you know instead of control structures
we can use a dictionary because that's
kind of our switch equivalent in Python
and somebody else comes in here and says
well we could use functional programming
instead and that's even fancier and all
three of these pieces of code accomplish
the exact same thing but there is some
justification need to say is which one
is best
how should we write the code if somebody
disagrees with the way the code is
written how do we litigate that that
disagreement and I and if we go back to
our diagram we can think well if we're
down this last column of users who
aren't particularly sophisticated then
obviously we want the most you probably
want the first approach if we're talking
about people in a corporate training
situation and I've done a lot of
corporate training you don't want to use
the last two options because you'll lose
them right off the gate you want to use
a simple option that's closest to what
they already know and if you're on the
other column then you're a little bit
freer to use whatever stylistic
complexity you want because you'd assume
their users are just going to breeze by
that it's not gonna stop them similarly
if you think about dynamic complexity
and this is a problem that we run into
in Python a lot we have enormous tools
for meta programming we have macro
systems in Python we have all sorts of
ways to add some distance between the
actual code mechanism that exists at
runtime and the source text that we've
written Mehta classes are one example
but you can think simply in Python you
can have a for loop and in that for loop
you can add things to your local
dictionary so you can programmatically
define functions in a for loop in a
module people don't generally do that
because certainly library authors don't
do that because they expect to have Co
contributors and that's a little bit
weird but there are there is the ability
to add some distance here and the
argument for adding that distance is the
fewer physical artifacts the fewer lines
of code I have to write the fewer things
I have to fix if I need to make a small
change I don't like to repeat myself
perhaps and additionally I get to have
you know central points where I can add
functionality that goes across all of
these
fairly similar use cases so in addition
so when we think about this do we want
to minimize physical artifacts and we go
back to our diagram we can see if we're
looking at the bottom row of our diagram
the users who don't care about our
project we can see something quite
stunning which is a user who doesn't
care about your tool but only cares
about using your tool is not going to
use anything more than the standard
tools that they have to understand your
code they won't learn your custom tools
they won't run your custom build system
they'll learn it only in so far as
building York tools so they can use it
and so if they want to make a one-line
change they're not going to jump through
20 pages of documentation to make a
one-line change they're gonna use tools
and techniques that they already know in
order to make that change and you can
see if you ever use any projects that
come out of Google they have enormous
complexity to their build system and for
some of us who don't want to be node
engineers but need to use node I don't
really want to learn
Google's build system to build node
because I don't care that much about
node it's just one component in my
system and I care more about the data
science that I'm doing and then piping
through you know a server that I'm
building then how the server is built
and how its constructed and if you look
at the tools that I'm going to use
they're almost all static tools they
almost all operate on source text
basically I'm talking about grep your
users are gonna grep for a line which
seems to be the change they want to make
if they can't find it they're gonna get
frustrated and so when you talk about
should I employ meta programming one of
the considerations is I lose artifacts
on disk that somebody can just grep for
and I lose the ability for contributors
who don't fundamentally care to learn
about my architecture to contribute to
this and so writing this the dumb way
writing it out repeating yourself
cutting pasting the code can actually be
much better because you'll have
contributors you can actually get a
foothold in that now if we look at our
diagram and we look at the bottom left
corner if we talk about users who are
smart users who are sophisticated but
they don't care about your tool you can
hedge that a little bit and you can talk
about something I like to say the
principle of import ability which is in
a Python module any Python module that
has some runtime mechanisms those
mechanism should exist on import so I
should be able to sit and say import
this module and I can look into that
module dynamically and see all of the
mechanisms that I'd use there shouldn't
be some additional registration
initialization step because it's not
what I'm gonna do if I want to
understand how a tool works and it's a
little bit more sophisticated I'm gonna
interact with it as a sophisticated user
using tools I know and Python using my
my interactive console and I'm gonna
import that module and use Durer and
help and so instead of grep I'll use der
and I might even write fancy things like
little list comprehensions that look
through the module contents to find
things that I want and as a
sophisticated user that's what I do but
I'm still gonna be fairly relying on a
degree of static Ness that you may not
want as a module author because you want
to use some fancy techniques to minimize
the amount of typing you have to do I
want to look at one more case type which
is self-indulgence because this is a
fantastic dick we all love to write code
that makes us feel smarter oftentimes
it's an opportunity to make you feel
Dumber and then smarter and then dumber
and then smarter again so it's a great
exercise for your ego if we look at our
diagram and we look at the top right
corner users who really care about our
tool and are also very sophisticated
this is an incredibly fertile ground for
us for random experimentation this is a
ground where we can do whatever we want
and we'll still get Co contributors so
you could see a lot of JavaScript tools
seem to be like this a lot of JavaScript
frameworks seem to be in this zone they
are incredibly complex and the users are
assumed to be very sophisticated and
there seems to be no barrier to how
complex they can be with somebody still
you know bang down the door to learn it
if we were to look at the opposite
corner of this quadrant users who aren't
very sophisticated and who don't care
about this tool this is something that
we actually end up seeing very
frequently in the tools that we have to
build because this qualities is
basically every tool that we build for a
semi-technical user a user who cares
about the results but doesn't care about
the process this is a user that's happy
a tool exists but they don't care it's
your tool they'll use whatever tool
against their job done but they don't
care if it's your tool they don't care
if you did it in some fancy fashion they
don't care if you added a new
abstraction in fact they would prefer
that you not be a pioneer you know how
you can tell a pioneer by the arrows in
his back I thought that was pretty good
the idea being that these users you
might find some fantastic way to solve
the problem your users will not care
they will not be willing to learn your
new technique because they just want the
result they don't care about the process
of its own this is an enormous number of
tools that we use a lot of command-line
tools are this way I would say even some
visualization libraries are this way one
marker of this is when you find that
your users refuse to use anything but
code that cut and paste from blog posts
from 10 years ago I'm looking at you Tom
Caswell from matplotlib it's a very
common thing that we see just getting
your users to care enough to actually
keep up to date with the documentation
and use modern techniques and to use the
code as you're currently developing it
so the question comes down to where is
my code where does it sit in these
quadrants and you might even say that
for different you for different users
there may be it may sit in different
quadrants one example came up when
trying to organize a tutorial for a PI
data event earlier this year where we
had somebody who gave a stats model
tutorial and they complained about
giving a stats model tutorial
they said it went horribly because we
needed the people in the audience to
know something about statistics I'd
rather give a scikit-learn tutorial
because you don't really need to know
anything about machine learning to use
scikit-learn and that was a very
provocative statement I thought and you
can think that the scikit-learn
developers certainly would not agree
with that but there are a lot of
statistical users who think well you
know the API is so simple we don't
really need to know anything to use this
tool and you can see that in that case
that tool is actually used by users in
very very distinct quadrants so you do
have to prioritize you have to
understand who are the users you
sufficiently care about which of those
quadrants to your to the users you care
about sitting you have to determine from
that what is your complexity budget and
that can guide you and how much
complexity can be applied you may in the
process discover that the problem is not
solvable or at least it's not solvable
with the current budget for complexity
in which case you might be able to find
or you might be motivate
to find an easier problem to solve that
gets you most of the way there you might
also find the problem is too hard for an
easy answer but in general what you're
trying to do is find some justified
reasoning for where you apply complexity
what do I use to justify in a
qualitative fashion whether this is too
complex or not complex enough so we
don't fall back on these absolutely poor
after isms like keep it simple stupid
that aren't anything but a personal
attack against people who write code
that doesn't look exactly like the code
that we write but we're actually making
a solid engineering judgment that serves
the task that our work is subordinated
to this is what I call a qualified
judgment and this is one simple
framework that I use for actually trying
to figure out all these things that I
give that I talk about in my different
PI data presentations what I ever used
in real life well this is part of my
judgment I want to thank all of you very
much I really enjoyed this talk I'm
James Powell
do we have time for questions
no there five minutes of questions
no questions nobody was that too
provocative I know I saw I think one
very important thing I want before I
answer the question is I mean yeah I say
smart and dumb and that's trying to rile
you up a little bit but really it is
very important to say that if you're on
a team with somebody and you're an
expert Python programmer and they're not
an expert Python programmer it does not
diminish them as a contributor to the
project or as a human being to not be an
expert Python programmer I think that we
see this attitude implicitly too much in
our industry it's okay to not know
something whether it's okay to not want
to know something I think that's fine to
some things I just don't care about but
you know we're all trying to solve a
problem and as long as we keep our eye
on the problem we're trying to solve
that's what's more important there was a
question oh so my top so I had three
people come up to me at this event say
oh yeah I saw you give a talk at SCI PI
or PI did in New York or something else
and I really liked it and I said oh
what's talk was that and I said I can't
remember
so that should probably give you an idea
of where it falls it's way off the axis
so it is unnecessarily complex because
all the things that it solves you could
just throw human labor at and probably
so that's the thing a lot of these
things the justification is do I want to
have one person come up with a really
smart solution or I used to work at a
big bank do I want to have 150 people
and a 20 million dollar budget to solve
the same problem and for the bank 20
million bucks is not really that much
money and 100 and wasting 150 people's
lives and times and energy and youth
they don't care I mean that's it's the
it's part of the metric that they have
some up for other for other ones it's it
doesn't make sense for read watches that
was that was just me trying to provoke
the audience yes
absolutely right yes it is yes it is
well at some companies it's it's that's
true
but if you have five or six newbies out
of a hundred people and they're only
newbies for six months if you told them
just don't look at this project until
you're six months in does that really is
that really a big deal I mean it's part
of the question you have to answer and I
think that if you have obviously you're
not going to go to a company and say
well I have some newbies and they only
know Windows so let's just throw all
this Linux garbage out the at the door
and the stalker garbage because they
can't figure it out because what will
happen if that organization is some will
say no no you know the rest of us have
been using this for five years the
newbies will figure it out right or
let's not use git because they didn't
learn it in school you never say that in
an organization right
you'd say they'll figure it out and
that's a fairly reasonable thing to say
in an organization at the same time you
might not want to say well you know
pythons kind of passe and Scala is
something that people have actually
heard about so let's use some language
nobody's ever heard about that nobody
uses just because it's fancy that's a
horrible idea because how are you gonna
hire people to actually be effective in
your team in a short period of time so
the argument can go both ways right
absolutely absolutely that's ice didn't
mention this in this talk because I was
seeing you know how you make how you can
be good for your organization but a
great way to spend complexities is what
I you know we're talking about budgets
right the situation with all budgets is
you have a certain budget of money and
you spend it judiciously until the end
of the year and then you gotta you gotta
spend it right so same with the software
project you have some complexity budget
and you make this a little bit complex
here a little bit complex your a little
bit complex here a little bit of
complexity leftover not for the end of
the year but when you see the layoffs
are coming you just go hog-wild at
something - the craziest thing you can
pad your resume and bounce and it's
pretty much the same thing right
that's career advice you heard it right
here and and and yet we've all we've all
seen or lived it I'm sure yes this is
the least provocative so where is
matplotlib as a core developer for a
project that almost everybody in this
room probably uses on a fairly frequent
basis how just decide whether you need
to do something fancy in that plot lib
or do it the dumb way layers layers so
you have a core of really smart stuff
and then layers of dumb stuff on top
passing a data port and you kind of
strength another variable to look those
strings up in the dictionary people
thought you said that was a are you
restraining this and the list of things
that are on every line fiction sighs did
anyone say whoa that's too much let's
just cut and paste and call it a day
string we are willing to accept the
complexity of a decorator on all of our
functions you have some people in that
top quadrant and some people and
majority people and well thank you thank
you Tom
there's my pleasure giving this
presentation and let's hear it for our
next speaker